well maybe all of this has to do with
joe biden's
completely cratering approval ratings
this guy entered office in the 50s
he was given the gift of a vaccine that
he did not develop
there was a distribution plan that he
did not develop he took advantage of
that all he had to do was not be
terrible at this it's incredible it
really is in life it is incredible how
much of being successful is just staying
out of the way of success but people
can't do it they got to get their grubby
little hands in there and joe biden had
to get his grubby little hands into the
economy and into coveted policy he had
to demonstrate that he was an important
person and it made him feel important
well guess what the american people are
about to make him feel pretty damned
unimportant in the midterm elections so
joe biden decided he was going to go on
with one of his late night sick events
this one was jimmy fallon i remember a
time when jimmy fallon used to be at
least somewhat humorous and then trump
broke his brain and all you've got now
is sort of the
feeble husk of jimmy fallon performing
bad stephen colbert knockoff interviews
so here he was with joe biden doing an
interview and and sucking up to him it
was not good guys
how much do you pay attention to
approval ratings
well
not anymore
[Laughter]
hey you can always uh my my favorite
thing about politicians is their tells
they're really fun so you've got com
commemoral harris tell us the actual
crazy laugh joe bidens tell us that
after he thinks that he told a joke he
wipes his eye like this this is a thing
that you watch for it it's kind of fun
okay and uh and that and jimmy fallon's
tell is that he has one of the worst
fake laughs in the industry it's a i
mean it's like kamala harris level fake
laugh yeah but it didn't stop there then
you had jimmy fallon again they're
trying to prop up this old man because
they got nothing nothing so here is
jimmy fallon praising joe biden for no
reason anyone can discern
a lot of republicans and democrats used
to get really on well together for
example one of the reasons that a little
bit late coming on is it because uh not
coming on but to do the taping here is
because i did bob dole's eulogy today he
asked me on his deathbed whether i would
do his eulogy we're friends we disagreed
but we were friends we gave you standing
ovation because i go here he is he's
bringing class back
he's a classy guy and you're bringing
class back to the office and i thought
it was
amazing that you did that
well it's so much class being brought
back to the office by the way in the
same interview joe biden started ripping
on republicans and on his political
opponents as anti-vaxx crazies and
suggesting that everything that's going
on is their fault so much class so much
class from joe biden
guess what the american people are not
falling for this they don't buy it and
here's the problem for democrats they
got nothing behind joe biden he's the
only thing standing between them and
complete collapse kamala harris is a
disaster area and now her team is
fighting back by saying that everyone
who points this out is a racist or a
sexist good luck with that particular
line of argumentation according to the
new york times addressing reporters at a
meeting of the democratic governors
association governor roy cooper of north
carolina gave an emphatic answer when
asked whether he expected joe biden to
seek a second term and whether he
believed that was in the best interest
of his party i do and i do said cooper i
fully expect him to seek re-election and
i will support him in fact we're gonna
win north carolina for him but three
minutes later cooper was sketching out
what could be the makings of a cooper
for president primary message he
trumpeted his repeal of the state's
so-called bathroom bill targeting
transgender people an executive order
granting paid parental leave to state
employees another order putting north
carolina on a path to carbon neutrality
by 2050.
publicly cooper and other democrats are
focused on what will be a difficult
2022. however it's 2024 that's
increasingly on the minds of a long
roster of ambitious democrats and their
advisors
no one is interested in kamala harris
she's a giant failure
pete booty judge is a complete nothing
bag
senator elizabeth warren is 8 000 years
old and blew it last time
amy klobuchar has no juice
it's it's it's a their bench is so weak
it's so insanely weak
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe